[Musique]
François ikcal bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement alors je m'appelle François
cal j'ai je suis à la base ingénieur de
l'École Centrale ensite je suis passé
par l'ENA nul n'est parfait euh j'ai
commencé ma carrière au ministère des
Finances dans une un service s'appelle
la direction de la prévision qui faisait
des prévisions économiques comme son nom
l'indique qui a ensuite été fusionné
avec la direction du Trésor donc j'ai
été responsable pendant plusieurs années
des prévisions de finances publiques je
prévoyais le déficit et la dette
publique dans les années 93 à 97 ensuite
j'ai intégré la Cour des comptes où j'ai
fait un travail normal d' d'un
conseiller à la Cour des comptes pendant
quelques années puis après on m'a
demandé d'écrire le rapport annuel de la
Cour des comptes sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques j'ai
fait ça pendant 8 ans j'ai été membre du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques et
puis bah il y a 8 ans maintenant 9 ans
le temps passe vite j'ai créé un site
internet qui s'appelle fipcho voilà
www.fipec.fr ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire finances publiqu et économie voilà
P et ou trouver tout ce que vous voulez
savoir sur les finances
publiques on a décidé de vous faire
venir parce que on a besoin de vos
lumières on a besoin de de vos
éclairages sur une échelle de 0 à 100
vous metteriez le pays dans quelles
conditions zéro on va s'effondrer et 100
on est en pleine croissance on est
vraiment vigoureux là on se trouve à
combien je sais pas 20 30 moins de la
moitié moins de la moyenne en tout cas
pas zéro non plus on n'est pas on n'est
pas au fond du
trou quand vous étiez
prévisionniste votre marge d'erreur
c'était
combien tout dépend de l'horizon à
lequel on fait ces prévisions évidemment
c'est plus difficile de prévenir de
prévoir l'avenir lointain que le le le
quasi présent mais quand on fait des
prévisions de déficit public alors c'est
toujours en point de PIB en pourcentage
du produit Inter brute parce que bon le
les milliards d'euros n'ont pas la même
signification aujourd'hui que il y a 20
ans euh mais on pouvait faire des des
erreurs à un horizon de je sais pas 4 5
ans euh de toute façon les prévisions
officielles étaient toujours normées
comme on l'appelait à l'époque
c'est-à-dire que ça ne correspondait en
rien aux prévisions qu'on faisait nous
en interne ces prévisions officielles
ont toujours été complètement fausses à
hauteur avec des erreurs qui était
pvêtre de deux ou trois points de PIB
hein euh et et les prévisions internes
lesté usement beaucoup moins un horizon
de 2 ans mais un horizon de 2 ans on
peut faire une pr une erreur de un point
de PIB et même je dirais à la fin de
l'année pour l'année en cours on peut
encore faire une erreur de 02 à 02 ou 03
points de PIB à l'heure actuelle on se
dirige vers quoi comment est-ce que nos
politiques on réellement pris conscience
de la situation est-ce que vous pouvez
nous nous faire au début de votre votre
réponse
un portrait de la situation française en
terme de financeces de perspective de
croissance alors je vais menir en effet
à ce que je connais c'est-à-dire les
finances publiques la croissance la
croissance la prévision officielle cette
année c'est une croissance de un peu
moins de 1 % je suis pas sûr qu'on y
arriveil y a quand même beaucoup de nuag
noir à l'horizon donc c'est pas évident
après les économistes vous diront que la
je dirais sans crise sans
catastrophe la prévision à moyen terme
c'est une croissance en moyenne qui est
de l'ORD de 1 % 1,2 % voà dans ces eau
là c'est pas terrible non plus c'est pas
nul non plus hein donc voilà donc ça
c'est c'est pour la croissance après à
plus long terme il y a beaucoup de débat
entre les économistes entre ceux qui
vont vous dire que si on regarde le
passé on est sur une tendance faible
voilà qui même va même temps
avoir tendance à à diminuer en revanche
il y a ceux qui croient que
l'intelligence artificielle les
nouvelles technologies et tout ça va
nous permettre d'avoir une croissance
fulgurante dans les années à venir moi
je suis euh entre les deux je sais pas
je me dis que en tout cas pour faire des
prévisions de finances publiques il faut
mieux être prudent l'expérience a montré
que en France comme dans beaucoup
d'autres pays la croissance elle
ralentit sur le long terme sur les 30 40
dernières années on est plutôt sur une
tendance à au ralentissement donc il
faut mieux poursuivre cette tendance
plutôt que d'espérer que tout d'un coup
ça va rebondir voilà donc ça c'est c'est
pour la croissance après les finances
publiques ça c'est beaucoup plus
embêtant donc on a une dette publique
qui est bon comme chacun sait plus de
3000 milliards d'euros c'est l'c he qui
dit ça donc une C Eurostat ça fait 110 %
fin 2023 c'était 110 % du produit
intérieur brut ça ça permet de se
comparer aux autres pays donc on était
quand même les 3è on est maintenant les
3è de l'Union européenne il y a plus que
les Italiens et les grec devant nous
alors en soit c'est pas forcément un
problème le Japon a une dette publique
beaucoup plus importante ce qui le
problème il est il tient au fait que c
l'évolution de cette dette n'est pas
contrôlée euh c'està-dire qu'elle il est
normal qu'elle augmente dans les
périodes de crise euh mais après on
devrait être capable de la réduire et ça
on en a beaucoup de mal en France on on
arrive tout juste à la stabiliser puis à
la crise suivante elle remonte une
marche d'escalier et bon et comme ça bah
elle est passée elle était à 20 % du
produit intérieur brut en 1980
aujourd'hui elle est à 110 et ça va et
ça risque de continuer parce que pour
simplement stabiliser la la dette
publique à son niveau actuel hein 110 %
du PIB il faudrait faire un effort
considérable alors ça dépend des
hypothèse de croissance de taux
d'intérêt et cetera mais j'ai signé une
tribune avec Oliv Blanchard il y a 2
mois qui est l'ancien économiste en chef
du FMI et qui est le grand spécialiste
justement de des prévisions de taux de
croissance de taux d'intérêt et en
reprenant ses propres hypothèses on
arrive à la conclusion qu'il faudrait
faire un effort de 120 milliards d'euros
4 % du produit intérieur brut pour
simplement arriver à stabiliser la dette
c'est énorme c'est colossal et on risque
fort de ne pas y arriver donc la dette
risque de continuer à augmenter jusqu'à
quand personne n'en sait rien euh
jusqu'à que les marchés financiers tout
d'un coup se mettent à ganberger dire ou
là il y a un problème on va pas être
remboursé donc vont faire monter les
taux d'intérêt ce qu' fera qu'aggraver
le problème et à ce moment-là tout va
dépendre de la réaction de la Banque
centrale européenne elle a les moyens
d'intervenir mais en principe c'est pas
sans contrepartie donc elle peut nous
obliger à prendre des mesures très dures
euh elle peut aussi ne pas intervenir
elle peut certains dans les marchés les
marchés financiers pensent pense que
toute façon on interviendra toujours
parce que on est tout big tout fa comme
disent les banquiers on est trop gros
pour que on on fasse défaut et c'est
vrai queaujourd'hui on imagine mal la
BCE laisser la France faire défaut ça
serait une telle catastrophe un tel
cataclysme surtout dans la situation
géopolitique actuelle on n'imagine pas
donc en fait la cour la Cour des comptes
dit on est au pied du mur moi je dis oui
il y a un mur devant mais on n'est
probablement pas au pied on sait pas à
quelle distance c'est le mur il est pas
voilà on sait à quelle vitesse on va
mais on sait pas où il est exactement il
est devant nous et on sait pas quand
quand on va l'atteindre la dette elle
peut continuer augmenter je sais pas
dans combien de temps mais un jour on
aura un problème et le le le le
principal problème pour moi c'est que ça
va dépendre un moment on va se mettre en
situation de dépendre de décisions qui
seront prises à Francfort donc c'est un
problème de
souveraineté on se retrouve avec
potentiellement un désastre sur la dette
concrètement pour les gens normaux de
tous les jours ça pourrait se manifester
comment il se peut fort bien donc que si
tout d'un coup les marchés se mettent à
s'inquiéter les taux d'intérêt montent
on se retrouve dans une situation où
dans ce genre de situation bah les les
banquiers font comme vis-à-vis d'une
entreprise qui il voi une entreprise qui
ne qui risque de pas rembourser ses
dettes dans un premier temps ils
augmentent les taux d'intérêts ou là il
y a un risque je des économistes
appellent ça une prime de risque on
ajoute au taux d'intérêt une prime de
risque bon et puis à un moment bah
forcément ça ça ne fait qu'aggraver le
problème les taux d'intérêt sont plus
élevés donc le problème s'aggrave et à
un moment les créanciers d'un d'un État
comme d'une entreprise finissent par
dire bah on arrête si on arrête alors
que bah on a besoin de se refinancer
parce qu'on a des recettes beaucoup plus
faibles que les dépenses bah ça veut
dire que brutalement il faut soit
augmenter brutalement les recette soit
réduire brutalement les dépenses alors
en général ça se passe pas comme ça
c'est rare les défauts de paiement des
des États en général un état bah en fait
comme pour les entreprises d'ailleurs
l'état il va voir son banquier c'est
financiers il leur dit j'ai un problème
on discute on discute donc je peux pas
vous rembourser je peux pas payer les
intérêts alors il faut que vous fassiez
un effort il faut restructurer votre
dette vous abandonnez une partie de vos
créances et moi bah je vais faire des
prendre des mesures de redressement puis
au niveau international il y a un
organise par exemple le FMI qui est
chargé de gérer ce genre de problème qui
joue le médiateur qui peut apporter de
l'argent aussi mais en général ça se
termine mal euh beaucoup de pays en ont
fait l'expérience en Europe plusieurs
pays méditerranéens on ont fait
l'expérience en 2011-22 ça se traduit
toujours quand même par des mesures très
dures pour la population et qui sont
imposés de l'extérieur on retombe sur le
problème de souveraineté vous avez pas
le choix euh le parce que en particulier
bah les jeunes économistes du FMI ou
de en en Europe on a un espèce de FMI
européen qui s'appelle le Mécanisme
Européen de Stabilité les jeunes qui
vont arriver dans un pays à qui on va
dire bon il faut que en 3 jours vous
trouviez des mesures de redressement des
finances publiques qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire ils vont aller au plus simple dire
vous avez un taux de TVA qui est
inférieur à la moyenne européenne vous
montez deux points le taux de TVA vous
avez des retraites qui représente 14 %
du produit intérieur brut la moyenne
européenne c'est 12 vous vous vous
réduisez même vous vous vous contentez
pas de de ne pas indexer les retraites
sur l'inflation vous les réduisez parce
que voilà c'est simple
donc concrètement vous nous annoncez que
les les retraites vont baisser je sais
pas un jour le risque il est devant nous
un jour là nos capacités à faire des
économies c'est quoi si on touche au
retraite par an on peut gagner combien
de milliards sur les 130 qu'on devrait
trouver pour pouvoir
euh éponger
ou du moins ralentir l'hémorragie bah si
par exemple si on prend les les les
retraité actuelles les pensions
actuelles qui représentent c'est le
quart des dépenses publiques hein c'est
le les retraites actuelles si vous
indexez les pensions de retraite sur un
point de moins que l'inflation vous
faites automatiquement en fait parce que
c'est totalement mécanique une économie
de 3 milliards à peu près parce que le
montant des retraite de base c'est 300
milliards euh si vous y rajoutez des
retraites complémentaires ça fait à peu
près 400 milliards donc un point de
moins que l'inflation ça fait une
économie automatique à ce moment-là de 4
milliards euh je signale au passage
d'ailleurs que les retraites
complémentaires laag Carco fait ça
depuis déjà quelques temps sans le dire
je dirais sans le crier sur les toits
mais la j Carco ne revalorise pas tous
les ans le point de le point de la j
Carco autant que l'inflation c'est
exactement la même chose personne ne
s'en émeut mais et en pratique ça se
traduit quand même de la même façon par
une perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
retraiter de votre expérience de
relation avec les
politiques ils comprennent ils
comprennent pas ils n'appliquent pas ils
sont dans le dénis ils ont des lunettes
roses il font quoi ah non mais je crois
qu'ils comprennent la plupart bon il y a
des exceptions mais la la plupart
comprennent de même que je crois que
beaucoup de Français sont conscients
qu'il y a un problème quand on regarde
les
sondages puis depuis longtemps on voit
qu'il y a une inquiétude sur l'évolution
de la dette du déficit et cetera le
problème de la France il est pas dans le
stade de cette difficulté il est dans
les solutions c'est-à-dire Queen
revanche quand on passe aux solutions il
y a plus aucun consensus il y a plus
aucun consensus entre les Français
eux-mêmes et et et donc entre les et
aussi ou je sais pas quel est le le
facteur déterminant l'un ou l'autre
entre les politiques voilà il y a d'un
côté il y a ceux qui vont vous expliquer
je dirais un extrême il y a pas de
problème il suffit de taxer les riches
et les multinationales he disons pour
simplifier lutter contre la fraude
fiscale puis de l'autre côté on va vous
dire ben il il suffit de lutter contre
la fraude sociale de renvoyer un certain
nombre d'immigrés chez eux et puis le
problème est réglé voilà on le le
problème c'est qu' on en est là on on en
est à des des recettes un peu magiques
euh qui sont très très loin qui je ne
dis pas qu'il y a pas de problème que
c'est pas de il y a pas des réponses à
apporter sur ces sujets mais c'est pas
de le c'est pas d'un niveau suffisant
pour régler ce problème de de reprise de
contrôle de la dette euh donc et donc le
problème de la France il est làin plus
plus généralement alors depuis des temps
très anciens le fait
que on veut plus de dépenses publiques
on veut plus de service public on veut
plus de redistribution mais on veut pas
payer plus d'impôts non plus euh je pay
beaucoup quand même on en paye déjà
beaucoup d'ailleurs oui donc il normal
qu'on veille pas en payer beaucoup plus
mais on veut quand même encore plus de
service public et de redistribution
c'est très vieux moi je je cite je dis
souvent relisez l'Ancien Régime et la
Révolution de toville vous verrez qu'il
y a des descriptions de l'ancien régime
de to F c'est exactement la même chose
qu'aujourd'hui à l'époque les Français
demandaient au roi plus d'aide et plus
de réglementation aussi mais il voulit
aussi payer moins d'impôts bon l'impôt
était un peu moins bien distribué à
l'époque c'est sûr mais quelque part il
y a voilà ce cette idée que l'État est
là pour régler tous les problèmes et
pour régler les problèmes B soit c'est
de la dépense publique soit c'est de la
norme et puis bah justement ça fait
finalement ça conduit à beaucoup
d'impôts et alors à certains moment on
baisse les impôts parce qu'on trouve
qu'on il y en a trop euh et puis on
s'aperçoit quelques années après que bah
ça ne s'autofinance pas donc le déficit
public augmente et donc on dit bon ben
on va à ce moment-là on va réaugmenter
les impôts il y a des cycles he comme ça
dans l'économie donc là on vient de
terminer un cycle de baisse des impôts
on est en train à mon avis de de passer
à la Phe suivante du cycle la partie
hausse d'impôts quand vous étiez maître
prévisionniste comment on fait une bonne
prévision une bonne anticipation on a
des sondes à gauche à droite on a du
terrain on a des petites lettres ou des
petites notes qui nous remontent comment
comment ça se
passe oh non c'est beaucoup plus en
chambre ce que font les les
prévisionnistes aussi bien du ministère
des Finances que ceux des organismes
privé l'OFCE rxcode ou des organisations
internationales d'abord il faut qu'ils
aient un cadre comptable de l'économie
c'est déjà et avec voilà il y a
l'investissement les exportations les
imports la sommation donc le il faut que
ce cadre comptable soit respecté que il
y a des équations comptables qui doivent
être respectées et ensuite bah il savent
par des méthodes statistiques on peut
voir sur le passé que bah par exemple
quand on augmente les revenus la
consommation elle augmente alors pas
autant que les revenus parce qu'il y a
une partie qui est épargnée et cetera
voilà donc on on a des modèles de
l'économie avec à la fois des équations
comptables des relations comptables et
puis des équations qui traduisent le
comportement des des agents économiques
les ménages ou les entreprises mais il
faut ensuite aussi beaucoup je dirais
c'est c'est en réalité c'est aussi très
artisanal c'est-à-dire que au-delà de ce
que disent les statistiques les modèles
bah il faut parfois aussi sentir que
aujourd'hui si on augmente les revenus
ça va peut-être se traduire peut-être un
peu plus par de l'épargne c'est c'est
c'estes modèles ont parfois beaucoup de
mal à je dirais à à refléter la réalité
donc parfois il faut s'en éloigner et on
est dans le dire d'expert mais donc
c'est très artisanal d'où beaucoup
d'erreurs beaucoup d'erreurs alors on a
des enquêtes aussi alors sur le terrain
mais le il y a des enquêtes de l'INC des
tas d'autres organismes qui font des des
enquêtes sur le terrain mais les les
enquêtes elles sont utilisées pour faire
des prévisions de très court terme parce
que les enquêtes elles vous disent
aujourd'hui par exemple il y a une
enquête que suivent beaucoup les
économistes qui est une enquête très
ancienne de l'INC sur le climat des
affaires qui est le sentiment des chefs
d'entreprises sur l'évolution de leurs
activités de leurs perspective
d'embauche et cetera c'est une enquête
très utile mais qui va permettre de
faire des prévisions à court terme sur
les 6 prochains mois les prochains mois
les prévisions à 1 an 2 ans voire plus
bah là on est plus dans les modèles
statistiques avec toutes les difficultés
à les
utiliser donc vos vos prévisions vos
anticipations est-ce que vous avez des
indicateurs à l'échelle mondiale est-ce
que vous vous suivez l'évolution de tel
ou tel pays l'évolution du prix du baril
l'évolution de certains gaz auuc qui
pète l'évolution de certains champs
d'uranium ou de nouvelles mines est-ce
que vous suivez ça l'international alors
moi non parce que moi j'ai pas les
moyens fipeco est une toute petite
association où je suis le seul à
travailler donc il a pas du tout les
moyens de faire ce genre de choses mais
les les prévisionnistes de ce soit de
l'administration les les les organismes
privés donc FCC fond oui bien sûr il y a
comment comment ils font ah c'est pas
évident par exemple vous avez cité le
prix du baril oou les taux de changeent
aussi on a beaucoup de mal
euh à prévoir l'évolution typiquement de
ces deux déterminants essentiels et la
plupart du temps dans les prévisions
économiques qui sont faites l'hypothèse
qui est faite finalement parce que
économiquement on s'est aperçu que on
savait pas vraiment faire mieux dans les
les les prévisions on gèle tout
simplement les tau de change ou le prix
du baril au dernier dernier niveau connu
sauf si on a vraiment de très bonnes
raisons de penser que ça va augment ça
va évoluer dans un sens ou dans l'autre
mais bien souvent l'hypothèse la plus
l'hypothèse la plus souvent faite
typiquement pour les taux de change et
et le prix du baril c'est il reste au
même niveau au niveau qu' atteint au
moment où je fais la prévision inchallah
ça bouge pas ça bouge pas c'est voilà il
y aance que ça aille dans un sens que
dans l'autre il y a d'autres paramètres
comme les paramètres de guerre les
paramètres de bateau qui bouche un canal
les les guerres sont imprévisibles en
tout cas les économistes ne ne savent
pas les prévoir et donc toutes les
toutes les prévisions qui sont faites à
moyen long terme et cetera sont toujours
des prévisions je dirais à environnement
international à changer he d'une
certaine façon quotidien les dividendes
de la paix tout va bien voilà on on on
prolonge des tendances passées on
prolonge des tendances passées après on
peut faire des exercices ça relève plus
de la prospective il y a des gens qui
font et l'administration le fait mais le
le le problème comment le fait comment
après alors là moi je suis pas je suis
pas un spécialiste là de de la
prospective JEE la question dans le sens
fait des scénarios voilà fait des
scénarios est-ce que vous utilisez tout
le spectre de l'État en terme de
renseignement pour faire non non non et
franchement enfin moi je je suis pas
enfin je suis pas sûr que ça avance à
grand-chose parce que je suis pas sûr
vous avez déjà fait de la voile dans ma
jeunesse oui c'est compliqué de sortir
un bateau sur les prévisions météo non
oui ben d'ailleurs elles sont souvent
fausses quand même les prévisions météo
mais bon c'est comme les pr les
prévisions météo c'est comme les
prévisions économiques c'est c'est
difficile c'est nécessaire il faut il
faut en effet avoir des prévisions météo
pour sortir à la voile mais j'ai quand
même même noter que parfois ça donnait
pas enfin la réalité s'éloignait des
prévisions mais c'est nécessaire pour ça
de la même façon les prévisions
économiques sont nécessaair mais c'est
aussi compliqué les prévisions météo
parce que ça demande à faire plein
d'hypothèses avoir des modèles aussi de
calcul qui sont qui sont extrêmement
compliqués euh c'est un peu en météo on
est un peu comme en économie oui mais et
on a du mal à prévoir les les les
événements extrêmes aussi en météo aussi
par donc les guerres typiquement B en
météo c'est les cyclones on sait que les
cyclones on en a plus à certaines
périodes à certains endroits mais on
n'est pas capable de prévoir 3 mois à
l'avance que il y a un cyclone qui va
frapper tel des Antilles en terme de
collaboration entre les services
d'intelligence économique de
renseignement de prévision économique du
budget où j'en
passe il y a un petit peu d'échange
d'information ils se mettent autour
d'une table ils se disent par exemple
méfiez-vous les économistes censé faire
des prévisions budget TER là on sent le
Moyen-Orient cramé ça risque de faire
des perturbations sur le baril jamais
jamais vous mettez autour de la table
avec les vos d'autres directeurs de de
si si non de temps en temps il y
a de temps en temps mais moi je suis
plus hein je là je parle voilà quand j'y
quand j'y étais mais bien sûr on regarde
enfin le le je dirais les les les les
prévisions économiques qu'on fait pour
la France un un des un des déterminants
essentiels de l'activité en France c'est
l'environnement international donc donc
on faisait des prévisions
internationales moi j'étais dans j'ai
été à un moment dans un bureau qui est
aujourd'hui la direction du Trésor où on
suivait les économie noneuropéenne donc
les États-Unis le Japon les pays en
développement à l'époque la Chine
c'était quantité négligeable voilà on su
on suivait ces pays donc on on regardait
toute la littérature tout ce qui se
disait en effet sur le sur ce qui
pouvait se passer dans ces pays al
surtout s sous un angle économique bien
sûr mais on regardait on avait des
relations avec le kedoray aussi de temps
en temps on discutait avec le avec des
gens du kedoret pour savoir un peu ce
qu'il pensaiit de l'évolution de ces
pays après on utilisait beaucoup aussi
quand même parce que les prévisions des
organisations internationales FMI
OCDE Commission européenne qu'on voyait
eux régulièrement parce que
régulièrement à l' CDE Femi il y a des
il y a des il y a des réunions
internationales notamment sur les
exercices de prévision on rencontre les
autres pays régulièrement moi à l'époque
par exemple par exemple tous les 2 ans
le CDE fait un rapport sur chaque pays
de CDE euh donc à l'époque en tant que
représentant de la France je discutais
le le rapport de l'OCDE sur les
États-Unis sur le Japon sur je sais quel
autre pays voilà donc oui
mais mais je
dirais on on on on ne prévoit
jamais des catastrophes ou des des
guerres ou des c'est qu on est quand
même toujours dans un dans un
environnement un
peu qui prolonge je dirais le le passé
et dans lequel il a il y a pas de
rupture ça me fait peur oui mais des
ruptures vous pouvez en avoir dans tous
les sens et vous savez pas dans lesquels
vous lesquels vous allez retenir à quel
horizon et cetera c'est extrêmement
difficile y a par exemple des scénarios
abissés c'est le
scénario bien moins bien et pas bien
vous donner à notre Ministre des des des
possibilités d'avoir une meilleure
lecture
une oui parfois on fait des bien sûr on
peut faire des scénarios différents mais
même d'ailleurs officiellement par
exemple il il y a un sujet don on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est les retraites
sur les retraites ce qui fait référence
entre guillemets c'est les projections
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
la la la variable
essentielle en matière d'évolution de de
de équilibre financier d'un régime de
retraite ce sont les gains de
productivité en fait voilà qui génèent
parce que les gains de productivité sont
à l'origine de la croissance et et donc
là sur les et donc le corps est amené à
faire des projections avec des
hypothèses de gain de productivité un
horizon de 50 ans puis qu'ils font des
des prévisions à l'horizon de 2070 donc
évidemment on sait pas quelle va être
l'évolution des gains de productivité
donc on fait on donc il présente des
scénarios mais on le leur a reproché
d'ailleurs on leur a dit bah oui mais
vous faites plein de scénarios alors on
sait pas quel est le le le bon scénario
et cetera moi je pense qu'ils ont raison
en effet de faire des scénarios
différents parce que avoir un scénario
central effectivement alors qu'on sait à
l'horizon 2070 ça pas beaucoup de sens
donc ils font des scénarios donc dans
certains de ces scénarios bah comme on
disait au
début on suppose que les gains de
productivité vont repartir à la hausse
parce que les nouvelles technologies
tout ça plaisir au minist ça fait
plaisir au ministres mais dans d'autres
scénarios beaucoup plus pessimiste bah
non prolonge on on va on a plutôt
tendance à avoir des gains de
productivité encore plus faible que dans
le passé donc on a tout un éventail de
scénario donc oui mais mais ce qui est
voilà euh ce que vous dites est
intéressant parce que il y a des tas de
gens qui vont en le reproche a été fait
au au corps justement de présenter des
scénarios disons c'est il y a trop de
scénarios on y comprend rienà
donnez-nous un chiffre
unique c'est pas vrai c'est B vous m'z
déconcentré comment comment vous
expliquez la mauvaise lecture de Bruno
leemire et la mauvaise lecture de
d'Emmanuel Macron concernant les dérives
du de notre déficit public c'était des
lunettes roses cétait ils ont pas
compris qu'il y avait de la TVA magique
il y avait de l'argent magique tout
était magique on était tous
contents pourquoi il y a eu une si
mauvaise lecture de notre dérive de
compte public c'était de la subordnation
de vote ils achetaient du calme ils
payaient du calme alors il s'assuraient
du calme pour leur quand j'étais quand
j'étais au ministère des Finances dans
les années 93 97 on avait toujours deux
jeux de
prévision les prévisions technique
interne et on appelait ça les prévisions
normées normées par le cabinet du
ministre et et et l'écart était d'autant
plus important qu'on s'éloignait dans le
futur et donc en 93 97 on avait des
prévisions officielles qui permettaient
d'aboutir qui disait que on aboutirait à
un déficit public de 3,0 % du produit
intérieur brut en 97 pourquoi parce que
97 c'était l'année de référence pour
entrer dans la zone euro et bah le
critère c'était il fallait ramener le
déficit à 3,0 et les Allemands nous
expliquaient que 3,0 c'est Dr coma nul
et pas Dr comma c'est 3,0 donc voilà
donc on avait des pré et moi je faisais
des notes en disant au ministre en
disant mais Monsieur le Ministre on
n'est pas à 3,0 en 97 on est entre 3,5
et 4 % donc on n'y arrivera pas et donc
comment tout ceci s'est terminé c'est
terminé alors on a trouvé quelqu un peu
fait un peu de créativité comptable mais
surtout ça s'est terminé par une
dissolution ratée au sens où ça continue
voilà Chirac a dissous en en 97 la
gauche est arrivée au pouvoir et quand
elle est arrivée bah elle a pris des
mesures de redressement d'urgence donc
par exemple une augmentation du taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés c'est un grand
classique qui finalement nous a permis
d'arriver à 3,0 pile après ça a toujours
été comme ça il y a toujours eu deux
jeux de prévision au ministère des
Finances et on a toujours présenté des
prévisions à moyen terme qui n'avaient
aucun sens dont le but c'était
d'afficher une réduction du déficit
public jusqu'à z0ro jusqu'à ces
dernières années depuis 3 4 ans on est
un peu moins ambitieux on se contente de
ramener le déficite public à 3 % du PIB
ou juste en dessous pourquoi bah pour je
dirais pour mon essayer de convaincre
nos partenaires européens et les
partenaires financiers que en effet on
va réduire le déficit public mais
derrière ces prévisions officielles il y
a rien il y a une croissance des
dépenses publiques des économies que
aucun ministre enfin quand on les fait
on ne sait pas du tout quel vont être
les ces économies qu'on va faire il y a
rien derrière mais on le sait depuis
longtemps et donc c'était exactement
pareil ces dernières années on a
présenté des lois de programmation des
programmes de stabilité avec des
prévisions qui arrivaient à 3 % du PIB
de déficit en 2027 puis après 2028 et
après 2021 ça a toujours été construit
de la même façon après ça c'est les
prévision je dire à moyen terme comme je
disais tout à l'heure quand on fait des
prévisions pour l'année en cours il est
politiquement c'est quand même plus
dangereux de faire ce genre de chose
parce que quand vous faites une
prévision pour l'année en cours vous
savez que l'INC va sortir le résultat au
mois de mars de l'année suivante donc
vous avez moins intérêt quand même je
dirais à truander la la les prévisions
techniques et donc
là il y a eu une bonne part dans ce qui
a été dans les prévisions pour 2023 et
2024 il y a eu aussi des erreurs
techniques il y a eu des erreurs
techniques de la direction du Trésor la
prévision est un art difficile je me
suis trompé
ils se sont trompés un peu plus que
d'habitude quand même après
techniquement on peut trouver des
raisons en fait on a eu une année 2022
par exemple qui a été bien meilleure que
ce qu'on pouvait
espérer en terme de de plus généralement
de de rendement des recettes fiscales
sociales et cetera les les le le le
produit de ce qu'on appelle les
prélèvements obligatoires c'està-dire
tous les impôts et les cotisation
sociale a augmenté beaucoup plus vite
que l'activité économique et on est
arrivé en 2020 2 dans une situation un
peu bizarre où on a quasiment battu un
record en terme de taux de prélèvement
obligatoire taux de prélèvement
obligatoire c'est le rapport entre le
montant de tous ces impôts et
cotisations et le PIB on a quasiment
battu un record après avoir fait 50
milliards de baisse d'impôts pendant la
période Macron depuis 97 c'est abérrent
euh et donc en 2023-2024 on a eu une
sorte de normalisation euh le taux des
prélèvements obligatoires a baissé les
les le les rentrées fiscales les les
recettes fiscales ont augmenté beaucoup
moins vite que le PIB céit un peu normal
il avait prévu à berc ils avaient prévu
que ça allait se normaliser mais
l'ampleur de cette normalisation a été
beaucoup plus forte que ce qu'ils
avaient prévu donc il y a une erreur
technique voilà c'est une erreur
technique je me dis peut-être que
j'aurais fait la même chose si j'avais
été à leur place je sais pas quand vous
me dites subterfuge compable quand vous
me dites bon on présente un déficit de 3
%
c'est des partitions de flutes c'est
pour éviter qu'on se fasse dégrader
notre notes c'est pour éviter d'avoir
des troubles sociaux avoir par exemple
les fonctionnaires qui se fâchent les
retraités qui se fchent parce qu'on
coupe dans le
gras pour présenter un bon visage bah
c'est pour on on on on prévoit toujours
on a toujours présenté des ce qu'on
appelle des programmes de stabilité
c'estd les programmes à moyen terme de
finances publiqu envoyé à la commission
européenne mais on a aussi en interne
des lois de programmation des finances
publiques donc qui ont toujours ont
toujours présenté une baisse du déficit
public voilà pour revenir soit à zéro
puis maintenant plutôt à à à 3 %
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça pour
rassurer nos partenaires européens il y
a des règles budgétaires en Europe qui
nous obligent en principe bah justement
à ramener le déficit public sous 3 % du
PIB qui nous oblige à baisser le rapport
de la dette publique au PIB s'il est
supérieur à 60 % du PIB donc on fait ça
pour montrer qu'on va essayer de
respecter ces règles budgétaires et pour
expliquer aussi au marchés financiers
que on va faire des efforts mais mais
mais on n'est pas capable de faire ces
efforts parce que on n'est pas capable
d'annoncer en même temps les mesures qui
permettraient d'y arriver alors ça pour
des raisons politiques et sociales parce
que bah à nouveau personne n'est
d'accord sur les mesures qui sont
nécessaires pour arriver à réduire le
déficit donc aucun et et ces mesures
sont toujours douloureuses hein euh que
vous augmentiez les impôts ou réduisiez
les dépenses c'est toujours de l'argent
que vous allez prendre à des ménage ou à
des entreprises donc politiquement c'est
toujours difficile et donc et ben
l'expérience montre que depuis 30 ans
aucun gouvernement n'a eu le courage de
le faire et puis s'il avait le courage
de le faire il est probable qu'il serait
pas réélu la fois suivante donc là là on
a baissé nos prétentions de réduction de
déficit c'est parce
que on est devenu moins crédible pas
parce que c'est devenu impossible déjà
déjà ramener aujourd'hui le le le
aujourd'hui enfin on a un niveau de
déficit aujourd'hui qui va être
probablement de sa on n pas encore le
chiffre 2024 mais on dit que ça sera
autour de 6 % du produit inter ça fait
180 milliards d'euros euh c'est c'est
beaucoup plus que tout ce qu'on a connu
quand même ces dernières années donc
revenir à Z0 c'est un effort gigantesque
donc on se contente aujourd'hui de
revenir un peu en dessous de 3 % et
d'essayer de de respecter les règles
budgétaires européennes voilà qui nous
demande pas d'aller en réalité était
beaucoup plus loin donc donc on a réduit
nos ambitions un peu par réalisme sans
courage politique sans volonté politique
sans acceptation de la population au
saigné à l'austérité à la baisse des
salaires ou à la baisse des retraites
dans combien de temps on va se prendre
le les cowboy du FMI ou la troyka en
France quand est-ce que la la la France
risque d'être mise sous tutelle bah j'en
sais rien c'est pour ça je dis à la cour
des je dis la Cour des comptes en fait a
tort de dire on est au pied du mur et à
l'époque quand j'étais à la Cour des
comptes je leur disais ne dites pas on
est au bord du gouffre on est au pied du
mur et cetera parce qu'on nen sait rien
le gouffre il est peut-être encore très
loin devant nous et si vous quand on
crie au loup et trop souvent et que le
loup n'arrive pas on finit par pu être
crédible et ça toutes les difficultés
dans de de faire la pédagogie sur les
finances publiques c'est c'est parce
qu'il faut arriver à dire on a un risque
à long terme on risque en effet le FMI
mais ce des mesures d'osté mais mais
mais mais mais personne ne peut vous
dire quand c'est on peut pas ça on est à
la merci de tout d'un coup d'un
mouvement de panique sur les marchés
financiers ça peut arriver dans 3 mois
comme ça peut arriver dans 10 ans euh
donc donc c'est difficile d'avoir un dis
enfin il faut pas avoir un discours trop
catastrophiste parce que si vous avez un
discours trop catastrophique et il se
passe rien pendant 10 ans bon plus ça
n'a plus aucun plus personne il fait
attention c'est pas c'est pas facile de
faire la pédagogie sur ce
sujet comment on fait pour réduire les
dettes quand on a des perspectives de
croissance nul voire négative
c'est-à-dire les perspectives de
récession sont plus envisageables que
des perspectives de croissance on fait
comment pour réduire la dette dans ce
climat là alors d'abord
euh aucun économiste n'imagine qu'on va
réduire la dette en euros euh les 3100
milliards d'euros ils ne vont faire
qu'augmenter la seule chose que disent
les économieses c'est il faudrait
arriver à la réduire au moins la
stabiliser en pourcentage du produit
intérieur brut pourquoi en pourcentage
du produit intérieur brut parce que le
Produit Intérieur Brut c'est la somme
des revenus donc c'est un peu l'assiette
sur laquelle on prélève les impôts et
les cotisations sociales donc l'idée
c'est la comme pour une une entreprise
peut voir sa dette augmenter si son
chiffre d'affaires augmente euh voilà le
tout c'est de respecter certains ratios
voilà et donc l'état c'est pareil sa
dette en euros elle peut augmenter si
les il y a des perspectives de
croissance et donc si des recettes
peuvent augmenter si le PIB peut
augmenter euh après si le PIB diminue ce
qui arrive parfois euh bah là la dette
elle ne elle ne peut qu'augmenter mais
mais mais c'est pas anormal à ce
moment-là euh quand le qu'on est
vraiment en
récession moi euh je suis quand même un
peu kénésien sur à court terme
c'est-à-dire je je vous dirais que dans
une période de récession ou de faible R
de faible croissance il est normal que
le déficit public augmente parce que les
recettes se cassent à figure et il est
normal que la dette augmente et c'est
même et c'est même plutôt souhaitable
parce que bah ça peut permettre de
relancer l'activité d'atténuer les
l'effet de la récession et cetera le
problème c'est après quand ça va mieux
quand ça va mieux ben il faut arriver à
ralentir la dette réduire le déficit
voilà et c'est ça qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à faire en France laisser la dette
augmenter lorsqu'on est en situation de
récession on sait faire on sait même
rajouter des plans de relance on sait
très bien faire mais en sens inverse on
sait pas bien faire quel regard vous
portez sur Elion musque le Dodge quel
quel regard vous portez
sur le président argentin Miley est-ce
qu'il faudrait faire ça en France non
parce que je pense qu'il est en train de
casser le l'état alors fait qu'il casse
l'État fédéral américain ça je dirais
c'est moins grave que si on casse le
l'État en France typiquement par exemple
aujourd'hui bon on parle beaucoup du
fait que il on il supprime la moitié des
effectifs du ministère de l'Éducation
fédérale mais il faut bien avoir en tête
que le ministère de l'Éducation fédérale
aux États-Unis fait pas grand-chose en
réalité d'ailleurs il a très peu
d'effectifs par rapport le le
l'éducation ça relève des États fédérés
euh et donc les effectifs et
l'enseignement il se fait dans les États
fédérés et pas au niveau de l'État
fédéral donc donc ça la la comp voilà la
comparaison avec la France est difficile
maintenant donc je pense qu'il fait sur
le ministère de l'Éducation américain
peut-être pas beaucoup ou des faits en
revanche quand par exemple il supprime
euh il gèle ou il supprime par exemple
les crédits de l'USAID euh je pense que
ça les les économies les les Américains
ne s'en rendront pas compte tout de
suite mais à un moment ça va ça va finir
un jour par leur poser des problèmes
parce que ce sont des programmes qui
quoi qu'on en pense il y en a qui sont
discutable bien sûr mais qui permettent
de résoudre un certain nombre de
problèmes sociaux dans un certain nombre
de pays ou de problèm de santé publique
euh si les Américains ne le font pas je
pense qu'il y en a d'autres qui feront à
leur place les Chinois en particulier
donc je pense que pour le c'est c'est
pas une excellente idée du du simple
point de vue de l'intérêt des États-Unis
à long terme et l'Argentin l'Argentin je
connais moins ce qui se passe en
Argentine j'avoue je vois dans la presse
qui s passe
euh j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup de mal à
apprécier en tout cas je pense pas
aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans une
situation en France où on a besoin d'y
aller à l' hache euh on a besoin de
faire des économies considérabl on na
pas besoin de je
dirais en matière par exemple d'effectif
public si déjà on arrivait à faire dans
l'administration des gains de
productivité équivalents à ceux qu'on
fait dans des dans les services privés
on pourrait réduire on pourrait quand
même réduire significativement les
emplois publics euh dans les
collectivités locales il y a plein de
gains de productivité à faire on n'est
pas obligé pour ça de couper dans tous
les sens à la au à la tronçonneuse
pourit gagner combien combien de
pourcent combien de milliards ça dépend
de l'objectif qu'on se donne mais on
peut gagner on on pourrait gagner
beaucoup de milliardes maintenant je moi
je suis quand même assez pessimiste he
je je je je pense qu'on pour des raisons
politiques sociales culturel on y
arrivera pas avec au en octobre dernier
avec l'Institut Montaigne euh et
d'autres on était trois on a publié un
papier dans lequel avec une espèce de
menu de mesures euh qui au total
permettrait d'arriver à 150 milliards
d'économies c'est le catalogue des
horreurs c'est-à-dire que c'est
là-dedans euh on dit bon on va supprimer
euh par exemple pour ce qui est des
collectivités locales elles sont
autonomes donc c'est elles qui décident
dans de de recruter et cetera la seule
chose que peut faire l'état c'est
réduire les subventions qu'il leur verse
on dit bon bah voilà on va supprimer de
20 milliards euh les 20 25 milliards je
crois qu'on a mis les subventions deétat
aux collectivités locales Hollande a
quasi on avait fait la moitié hein quand
même il supprimé 12 milliards de
dotation au collectivité local ça a eu
des effets donc là ça a fait hurler les
élus locaux bien sûr donc là on propose
dit bon bah sur les collectivités
locales il faudra faire deux fois plus
voilà on on peut mais on le fera enfin
je suis bien conscient qu'on ne le fera
pas donc je pense que la dette publique
va continuer à augmenter donc un jour on
sera dans le mur je sais pas quand dans
5 ans dans 10 ans j'en sais rien mais on
y arrivera un jour donc ça c'était
l'entrée au menu des horreurs le plat de
résistance c'était quoi
ouais alors je pense que il y a une
mesure il y a il y a une une mesure qui
est qui est une des meilleures mesure
pour réduire le déficit public ça
consiste à augmenter la population
active faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
de gens sur le marché du travail parce
que quand on augmente la population
active on voit tous les exemples
étrangers le monde qu' a plus ou moins
long terme si vous augmentez la
population active de 100000 personnes ça
fait 100000 emplois en plus il y a une
corrélation qui est quasi parfaite et
donc pour ça il y a aujourd'hui en débat
un un moyen ça c'est de faire en sorte
que les Français partent plus tard à la
retraite donc la la combien de plus tard
ça dépend de l'objectif que vous vous
donnez déjà arrivé je pense que ça sera
déjà bien qu'on dans le contexte actuel
qu'on arrive
à à main maintenir les les effets de la
réforme pour maintenir la réforme de
2023 faut avoir en tête que dans le cas
de la réforme de 2023 donc on joue
essentiellement sur l'âge minimal de
départ la retraite donc qui passe de 62
à 64 ans mais comme il y a des tas de
gens qui de toute façon partaient
au-delà de 62 et même au-delà de 64 ans
ça va pas se traduire par une
augmentation de 2 ans de l'âge effectif
moyen de départ à retraite en fait ça va
conduire à une augmentation de cet âge
moyen de départ la retraite de un peu
moins d'un an de 9 mois à peu près
seulement donc je pense que l'essentiel
si le Conclave se poursuit l'essentiel
c'est d'arriver à ce résultat sachant
qu'il y a d'autres moyens que l'âge
minimal pour y arriver il y a un autre
moyen dont on a beaucoup discuté qui est
par exemple d'inciter les Français à
partir plus tard en augmentant la durée
de cotisation nécessaire pour avoir le
taux plein comme on dit t d'âge minim
aujourd'hui c'est 42 ans il est prévu
que ça passe à 40 3 on pourrait par
exemple dire un bon résultat du conclave
pour moi ça serait de se dire bon
d'accord on va pas jusqu'à 64 ans pour
l'âge minimal on reste à 63 ans mais en
contrepartie bah on augmente de en fait
de plus qu'un an en fait 1 an 2 ans le
le la durée de cotisation le nombre
d'années de cotisation pour avoir le
taux plein on peut voilà on pour à mon
avis on doit pouvoir arriver à trouver
des des solutions de ce type maintenant
je suis pas sûr qu'on y arrive parce que
les partenaires fin du côté des
syndicats c'est pas
vraiment des parties à gauche c'est même
d'ailleurs à droite du côté du
rassemblement national c'est pas
vraiment ce qui est visé donc entrée
plat et dessert c'était quoi pour
gratter un peu de milliard bah vous avez
des retraites vous avez la santé après
si vous prenez les dépenses publiques
par ordre d'importance donc le premier
poste c'est les retraites le deuxème
poste c'est les l'assurance maladie ça
fait à peu près 20 % des dépenses de
santé alors c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué l'assurance maladie parce que
dans le cas des retraites on voit bien
qu'en jouant sur deux ou trois
paramètres le le le taux d'indexation
l'âge de départ la durée de cotisation
on a des effets assez mécaniques
prévisibles euh dans le cas de la santé
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que dans
le cas de la santé on a des des des
dizaines de milliers d'acteurs c'est les
médecins qui qui prescrivent euh c'est
très
difficile c'est très difficile il faut
jouer sur des tas de de paramètres sur
le les tarifs des uns et des autres
arriver sur les réorganisations en
matière de santé il faut arriver à
réallouer les moyens il y a des endroits
où il y a trop de médecins il y en a
d'autres il y en a pas assez il y a une
très grande inégalité de répartition en
fait des des moyens hospitaliers par
exemple enfin voilà il y a des tas il y
a des tas de sujets sur lesquel il
faudrait avancer donc entrée plat
dessert digestif est-ce qu'on réduit le
train de vie de
l'État alors ça c'est ça fait ça fait
beaucoup ça fait de très bonnes
émissions le train de vie de l'État euh
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle le train de
vie de l'État les gens ont tendance à
penser que le train de vie de l'État
c'est les frais de l'éisée ou de
l'assemblée et cetera quand on fait le
total des dépenses de l'Élysée de
l'assemblée du Sénat du Conseil
constitutionnel et cetera on arrive à un
peu plus de 1 milliard
d'euros 1 milliard d'euros sur 1600
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
c'est même pas un milliè des dépenses
publiques alors c'est important d'un
point de vue symbolique
bien sûr psychologiquement bon d'accord
bien sûr mais en terme d'enjeux
financiers c'est peinuts c'est rien
alors si on va un petit peu plus loin et
que quand on parle de train de vie de
l'État on y ajoute je dirais les
dépenses de fonctionnement des
ministères des ministères cent enfin des
administrations centrales on peut aussi
parler des des des administrations
centrales des collectivités locales
c'est pareil là évidemment c'est un peu
plus mais quand on regarde quand on fait
des comparaison internationale c'est pas
là on se distingue le plus des autres on
appelle ça dans la dans les
nomenclatures de dépenses publiques
internationales appelle ça les les frais
pas les frais généraux les fonctions
support voilà c'est pas en point en
pourcentage du produit intérieur brut
c'est pas là où on se distingue le plus
donc il y a des efforts à faire bien sûr
il faut en faire il y a des économies à
trouver mais
attention ça si on veut faire des
économies vraiment colossal pour arriver
qui sont nécessaires pour stabiliser la
dette ça ne suffira pas selon vous on on
y arrivera jamais non je pense qu'on y
arrivera qu'un jour forcé en effet par
une crise on y arrivera qu'en temps de
crise mais ceci dit c'est c'est souvent
le cas dans dans les autres pays ça
quand même a été souvent le cas hein il
y a un pays qui a fait des efforts
considérables par exemple pour réduire
ses dépenses publiques c'est la
Suède dans les années 80 euh les
dépenses publiques suédoises en
pourcentage du PIB toujours pour faire
des comparaisons était nettement plus
élevé que celle de la France vous trou
des hydrocarbur au même moment non les
Suédois non les Norvégiens oui mais les
Suédois non non non les Suédois il quasi
ont quasiment rien un peu un peu de
quelques forêts mais bon c'est pas très
non non et mais ils ont réduit fortement
leurs dépenses publiques dans les années
90 d'à peu près 10 points de PIB c'est
comme aujourd'hui si on faisait 300
milliards 300 milliards d'économie c'est
je test mais ils l'ont fait sous la
pression parce que ils ont eu au des
début des années 80 une vraie crise
financière ils ont été obligés de monter
leur tour d'intérêt à 500 % ça a été
très très douloureux et donc là il avec
un consensus à la suéoise on revoit tout
ça on revoit notamment notre modèle
social ont réduit nos dépenses publiques
et aujourd'hui ils vont très bien mais
donc ils l'ont fait sous la pression les
les le Portugal l'Espagne aujourd'hui
ils vont beaucoup mieux parce que ils
ont fait des réformes mais ils les ont
fait sous la pression des marché de la
BCE voilà au début des années 2010 donc
c'est vrai que beaucoup de pays ont fait
ce genre de choses que sous une pression
extérieure vous êtes à la retraite oui
votre retraite s'est basée sur les 6
derniers mois les plus importants oui
bien sûr comme pour tout fonctionnaire
les 6 derniers mois oui c'est 75 % du
des du maximum c'est ça c'est 75 % du du
traitement des 6 derniers mois hors
prime
vous les les fonctionnaires vous
préciseront alors que alors dans le
secteur privé si vous avez le taux plein
dans le régime général c'est 50 % du
salaire moyen des 25 meilleures années
mais on y mettant toutes les primes et
il faut y ajouter la GIR Carco la j carc
qui fait à peu près la moitié donc vous
arrivez à un taux de remplacement d'à
peu près 75 % et donc dans le public
c'est so aussi 75 % décid au total je
dirais enfin sur ce sujet qui qui don à
beaucoup de débats il y a eu beaucoup
par exemple il y a eu des travaux dans
lesquels on a essayé de de calculer ce
que gagneraiit les fonctionnaires à la
retraite si on leur appliquait les
règles du secteur privé donc les 25
meilleures années en ajoutant la GIR
Carco sur l'ensemble du salaire et donc
y compris les primes en moyenne on
aboutit quasiment au même résultat avec
une grande disparité c'estàdire qui
dépend beaucoup du taux de prime
justement de grands écarts et donc
globalement je pense que c'est pas
tellement le le mode de calcul de la
pension qui qui qui d'une certaine façon
favorise les fonctionnaires ce qui les
favorise beaucoup plus c'est les
possibilités de départ anticipé ce qu'on
appelle dans la fonction publique les
catégories actives et superactive vous
avez quelques centaines de milliers de
fonctionnaires de l'État ou des
collectivités locales ou des hôpitaux
qui peuvent partir 5 à 10 ans don l'âge
minimal de départ et 5 à 10 ans
inférieur à l'âge minimal de droit
commun c'est c'est surtout ça le le le
gros le principal avantage de la
fonction publique pas tellement le mode
de calcul 6 mois contre 25 meilleures
dernières années parce que il y a prime
ou pas prime c'est compliqué on fait
quoi avec la retraite des
boomer bah la mienne par exemple bah la
retraite des boomers je pense que si on
veut faire des économies significatives
il
faut l'indexer sur moins que fion voilà
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
très mécanique
euh les les les boomers vont vous dire
il des boomers vous vous expliquez ah
oui mais c'est pas juste parce que j'ai
cotisé toute ma vie voilà donc ma
retraite c'est sacré et cetera sauf que
c'est une
erreur ça veut dire qu'ils ont pas bien
compris comment fonctionnait en France
un régime par répartition ils n'ont pas
cotisé pour leur retraite ils ont cotisé
pour la retraite de leurs parents ou de
leurs grands-parents qui qui eux avaient
une retraite beaucoup plus faible parce
que les retraites se sont quand même
nettement amélioré au cours des des des
dernières décennies donc ils n'ont pas
cotiser pour leur retraite et quand on
n'a pas suffisamment d'enfants
globalement c'est le cas en France comme
dans d'utre pays ben dans un régime par
répartition ben votre vous ne pouvez pas
avoir la même retraite que vos propres
parents
donc donc le je dirais le le le ressenti
malheureusement les le quand ils disent
c'est un juste parce qu'on a cotisé
c'est c'est en fait c'est faux c'est
c'est une mauvaise compréhension du
système ça marche pas comme
ça donc là pour résumer si j'ai bien
compris notre marge de manœuvre est
épaisse comme une feuille de papier
cigarette
ouais on est dans un climat de guerre de
guerre économique qu'est-ce que ça va
faire quand on va passer notre économie
en économie gu qu'est-ce que ça va faire
ça va faire de la croissance magique
alors bonne la une bonne nouvelle bonne
nouvelle dans le dans ce contexte c'est
ce que font les Allemands en ce moment
euh s'ils le font vraiment c'est-à-dire
que sil s'engage sur un programme de
dépenses supplémentairire quand même
assez massif qui d'ailleurs sera pas
uniquement de dépens militaire si j'ai
bien compris leurs accords il y aura
aussi de la dépense environnementale des
infrastructures et cetera donc ça ça ça
fera plus de croissance en Allemagne
euh qui va tirer le reste de l'Europe
euh donc quelque
partais c'est enfin voilà c'est un peu
une une bonne c'est une bonne nouvelle
d'un point de vue économique dans le
contexte actuel ça devrait tirer le
reste du monde maintenant ça peut aussi
faire plus d'inflation parce que si je
veux dire si vous faites beaucoup plus
de dépenses militaires les dépenses
militaires ça fait de la croissance
parce que bah on produit des chars et
des avions donc on distribue des
salaires c'est consommé on augmente
autre chose mais les chars et les avions
ça ne se consomme pas euh donc ça fait
pas autant de de produits de
consommation euh donc les gens ont des
revenus parce que on augmente les voilà
on augmente on distribue des revenus
mais il y a pas autant de produits de
consommation qui arrivve sur le marché
donc ça risque de faire aussi plus
d'inflation et et et éventuellement plus
d'importations donc euh mais bon mais
globalement c'est quand même favorable à
la croissance donc c'est plus c'est
plutôt bien les Allemands ayant la eux
la possibilité de le faire du point de
vue budgétaire parce que ils ont une
dette publique qui est aujourd'hui euh à
à peine supérieur à 60 % du PIB quand
ils vont aller sur les marchés se
financer ils vont être très attractifs
ils vont être très ils le sont de toute
façon
nous nous quand on va se pointer
derrière on va être un peu du deuxième
choix non à votre avis bah on est déjà
du deuxème choix d'ailleurs le marqueur
l'indicateur que suivent tous les
marchés financiers qui
justement représente le le la confiance
plus ou moins grande ance des marchés
envers la dette française ou la dette
allemande c'est l'écart de taux
d'intérêt ce que les les spécialistes
appellent le spread entre les taux
d'intérêt français les taux d'intérêt
allemand ce ce spread il était ces 10
dernières années il était à peu près de
50 points de base un demi-point de de
taux d'intérêt et puis il a augmenté
après la dissolution les marchés se sont
dit la France rentre dans une période
d'instabilité et cetera il est passé à
7080 il bouge pas beaucoup que c'est
c'est plus queavant ça devient
maintenant ça devient plus que le le
spread sur les taux portugais espagnol
et cetera c'est encore moins que
l'Italie mais donc c'est pas terrible
mais ça ne dénote pas non plus une
inquiétude particulière des marché
financiers ça r ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le mur il est pas forcément
devant nous là il est peut-être il est
sans doute plus loin sais pas à quelle
distance mais il est pas pour les les
les les il en tout cas pour le moment
les ne s'inquiète pas et même après c
ces déclaration cette déclaration de
l'Allemagne tous les taux d'intérêt ont
augmenté donc dans toute l'Europe mais
l'écart entre taux français et taux
allemand n'a pas beaucoup bougé donc oui
ça les taux d'intérêt vont monter
notamment parce que il y a des risques
d'inflation dans toute l'Europe mais
l'écart français allemand pour le moment
en tout cas n'est pas ne bouge pas
qu'est-ce qu'on doit surveiller pour
anticiper le mur le choc c'est un peu
comme un aveugle qui tape à gauche à
droite pour entendre l'écho qu'est-ce
que vous surveillez en terme d'indice en
terme de tendance pour sentir l'air du
temps bah cet indicateur ce spread c'est
celui qui est suivi par les marché et
donc en fait c'est celui qu'il faut
probablement suivre le plus parce que
les marchés ont des comportements
moutonniers c'est-à-dire que s voit que
ce spread augmente un peu trop ils vont
se dire ou les autres pensent queil y a
un risque risque si les autres pensent
queil y a un risque moi je prends un
risque aussi et et donc tout tout tout
le problème il est là c'est que tout
d'un coup ça se tout le monde se met ils
se mett tous à gambberger et et à
vouloir avoir des taux d'intérêt plus
élevés et donc à ce moment-là ce spread
ce qui est arrivé en 2011 2012 ce ce ce
fameux spread pour les pays
méditerranéens il est monté à 400 points
de PIB 400 points de base et même le
celui de la entre la France et
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui il est à 7080 en
201122 il était monté à 150 points de
base tout ceci ne s'est calmé que le
jour où Mario dragi a dit la BCE va
pouvoir intervenir va racheter des
dettes publiques whatever et Tex quoi
qu'il en coûte ça a totalement calmé les
marchés donc aujourd'hui tout à nouveau
tout repose là-dessus que que que va
faire la BCE si tout d'un coup en effet
les marchés se mettent à s'inquiéter si
ce spread se met à augmenter brutalement
qu'est-ce qui se passe si la BCE se
transforme en bas de banque à racheter
tous les actifs pourris et en mettant ça
derrière sa son blanc sein son sa
crédibilité qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
la BCE en fait n'a plus de crédibilité
bah le risque à ce moment-là c'est que
bah en fait c'est un peu comme si la BCE
faisait marcher la planche à billet hein
noquement voilà on augmente la masse
monétaire c'est un peu plus compliqué
aujourd'hui c'est pas des billets c'est
plus virtuel ENF c'est un peu le même
principe donc on fait tourner la planche
à billet comme on a su le faire dans le
passé dans des tas de pays compris en
France et donc ça fait en fait ça fait
plus d'inflation ou plus d'importation
par que c'est triste oui oui donc ça
fait de l'inflation ça fait de
l'importation et donc le et le problème
c'est que la BCE le mandat de la BCE
c'est de lutter contre l'inflation et et
et nous avons des partenaires dans le
nord de l'Europe et de l'autre côté
duurin qui sont une certaine allergie à
l'inflation ils ont des mauvais
souvenirs encore côté luutérien côté
luutérien donc voilà et donc le problème
c'est que la la BCE ne peut pas non plus
accepter ça euh et c'est pour ça que
à un moment si les choses se tournent
mal on sait pas très bien ce que va
faire la BCE parce que d'un côté elle
peut pas laisser la France ou même
l'Italie d'ailleurs faire défaut parce
que ça serait un cataclysme mais d'un
autre côté elle peut pas non plus
accepter que tout d'un coup on laisse
filer la la la planche à billet et avec
des risques d'inflation et à ce momentlà
le risque que bah la limite il y a des
pays du du nord de l'Europe qui sortent
de qui sortent de l'euro disons on en a
marre on veut plus payer pour le Club
Med comme disent parfois les Allemands à
propos des des pays méditerranéens on
veut plus payer pour le club me on se
tire donc la BCE sera prise entre ces
deux risques je sais pas al un dilemme
je sais pas quelle décision elle va
prise elle va prendre qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez répondre à ceux qui disent oh la
dette c'est pas grave on vendra la tour
effffel alors certains économistes vous
dire vont vous dire ils ont pas que en
face de la dette publique il y a des
actifs il y a un bilan des
administrations publiques donc état
collectivité locale organisme de SQ
quand on fait ce bilan ces comptes de
patrimoine on voit que pour le moment
les actifs sont encore supérieurs au
passif mais enfin le ça ça le rapport
entre les deux diminue il est sur une
mauvaise temps mais pour le moment c'est
vrai maintenant quand on regarde ces
actifs c'est quoi en effet c'est la tour
effffel vous voulez mais c'est sur c'est
surtout des terrains c'est des terrains
des bâtiments des routes parce que tout
ça a est évalué je dirais aucoup de
construction euh où évalue augmente dans
le temps quand les prix de le prix des
terrains augmentent quand les prix de
l'immobilier augmentent mais tout ça
c'est pas c'est pas il y en a un peu qui
est cessible oui bien sûr mais
l'essentiel de tout ça c'est pas
cessible les terrains c'est tout ça les
terrains les bâtiments voilà c'est les
terrains les bâtiments des ministères
c'est les terrains militaires c'est les
routes on va pas vendre on peut mettre
en concession des autoroute ça on sit
faire mais en revanche la voirie
municipale je vois pas très bien comment
on va faire pour la vendre c'est une
bonne idée de mettre les autoroutes en
concession c'est on l'a probablement pas
bien fait à l'époque où on l'a fait euh
qui l' fait bon alors ah non alors les
il y a deux choses il y a la mise en
concession ça c'est très ancien c'est
pas forcément une mauvaise idée parce
que ça a permis à l'état de finalement
de faire financer la construction des
autoroutes alors qu'il avait il avait
pas beaucoup d'argent ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui est plus contestable c'est
d'avoir c'est d'avoir privatisé parce
que jusque au début des années 2000 les
concessionnaires d'autoroute étaient des
entreprises publiques il y avait un seul
concessionnaire privé qui était
coffeirout historiquement mais qui
n'avait qu'une petite partie du du
réseau et donc la discuss la la décision
qui est plus contestable c'est d'avoir
privatisé ces concessions qui étaient de
de avec des sociétés publiques de les
avoir privatisé au début des années 2000
la privatisation ne s'est pas faite à
mon avis dans des conditions très bonnes
euh totalement transparent
et donc bon ça se mais maintenant c'est
fait c'est c'est fait le le le sujet
maintenant c'est de savoir ce qu'on va
faire dans d'ici quelques années que la
plupart de ces concessions arrivent à
échéance entre 2030 et 2035 vous avez de
l'épargne bah oui j'ai d'épargne ou oui
vous avez bénéficié de vos prospectives
et de vos prévisions pour faire un petit
peu grandir votre épargne al j'ai j'ai
de l'épargne qui résulte de ma
rémunération de voilà de fonctionnaire y
compris à la Cour des comptes j'ai aussi
une épargne personnelle
héritée vous faites comment pour éviter
qu'on vous le
pique
je je fais rien de particulier parce que
de toute façon sur lepque ça sera ça
prendra des formes qui sont
difficilement prévisibles c'est dépendra
de décision politique je diversifie
voilà c'est une épargne diversifiée
entre l'immobilier le les actions
l'assurance vie le monétaire je
diversifie vous avez des Bitcoin non
qu'est-ce que vous penseer des Bitcoin
en tant
qu'écononiste c'est pas ma spécialité
euh c'est pas ma
spécialité
je je trouve que ça a coûté quand même
très spéculatif c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire ça monte ça descend voilà j'ai un
peu peur que ça permet de de de faire
passer des opérations que on n pas envie
de faire passer sous les radars
officiels donc c'est un excellent moyen
de de blanchir des capitaux et cetera
donc ça me gêne quand même beaucoup de
ce point de vuel
euh donc je suis
[Musique]
pas
je j'ai rien compte je ferais je si j'ai
si j'en avais le pouvoir je n'interdirai
pas les bitcoins mais je faciliterai pas
non plus leur leur développement je
resterai neutre et à personnel
j'investis pas là-dedans qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire de l'agencification
de
l'État alors c'est un sujet à la mode
oui d'ailleurs j'ai été auditionné par
la commission d'enquête du Sénat sur ce
sujet bien fendu la la poire oui oui
c'était assez amusant bon une très bonne
humeur dans cette commission d'enquête
heureusement d'ailleurs
euh problème c'est qu'on sait pas
d'abord on sait pas très bien ce que
c'est que des agences comme je rappelais
à la commission d'enquête mais elle le
savait déjà on dit qu'il a 1200 agence
ça ça ça ça repose sur un rapport qui
date déjà il y a y a 15 ans et dans
lequel on mettait là-dedans en fait des
services de l'État qui n'ont alors qu'à
priori quand on dit agence on pense
quand même à des entités autonomes par
rapport à l'État qui ont une une
personnalité juridique morale donc dans
ce rapport de de 2012 bon il y avait des
services de l'État bon si on retire ça
si on uniquement je dirais des
organismes qui ont une personnalité
juridique autonome il y a deux listes
officielles il y en a une où il y en a
450 et l'autre où il y en a 700 DIRIS
c'est déjà
beaucoup le modèle d'agence il est pas
absurde en soi quand on a créé ces on a
beaucoup développé ces agences par qu'on
entend comme agence c'est quoi alors
c'est des choses très diverses ça va de
les universités sont des agences sont
les opérateurs parce qu'on les a rendu
autonomes dans les années 2000 on a on
on on on a créé voilà on a rendu les les
universités juridiquement autonomes donc
il y a plein quelques dizaines
d'universités il y a des dizaines et des
dizaines de d'écoles toutes les écoles
d'enseignement supérieur ça va des des
Mines de Paris HC voilà il y en a ce
sont des agences si on prend cette ce
sont on prend cette définition enfin
celles qui sont publiques hein bien sûr
je dis à chausé c'est une erreur parce
qu'elle est privée mais les mines de
Paris Centrale Paris nous je viens c'est
une agence euh voilà donc il y a tout ça
il y a les après vous allez avoir les
musées vous allez avoir et puis vous
avez des tous les les centres de
recherche le CNRS le CEA l'ADEM dont on
parle beaucoup mais il y en a plein
d'autres agence pour replacer les
copains c'est quoi alors vous en avez
moi que le bah quand on m'a posé la
question à la commission d'enquête j'ai
j'ai signalé le cas de l'Agence
Française des infrastructures de
transport c'est une agence qui qui gère
des milliards d'euros de de subventions
au transport ferroviaire
fluviaux aérien alors que l'État
pourrait très bien faire ça lui-même
euh qui qui entre permet d'entretenir
une certaine opacité sur le financement
des transports parce qu'il y a des fonds
qui partent de l'État qui vont dans
cette agence qui reviennent à l'état
c'est très très compliqué et donc la
Cour des comptes dit depuis longtemps
qu'il faudrait la supprimer alors ça
permettrait pas de faire beaucoup
d'économie parce que en fait il y a
qu'une dizaine de personnes qui
travaillent donc en terme de dépenses de
fonctionnement c'est quand même pas
beaucoup et et les milliards qu'elle
gère bah de toute façon il serait com
enfin c'est l'état les gérerait
directement mais c'est une agence que
donc je sais pas combien est rémunéré le
président de laad agence mais c'est un
poste enfin ça a l'air d'être un poste
intéressant il y a eu de des exemples
dans le passé de
recasage au niveau de la présidence de
cette agence il y a moyen d'économiser
combien si on gratte un peu sur les tous
les comités théodu et
Agen les comités théodu on ne même enfin
c'est comme cette agence des
infrastructures de transport quand ils
ont 10 personnes c'est déjà beaucoup euh
donc si vouslez supprimz vous allez pas
faire énormément d'économie ça peut
avoir des effets sur alors il y a des
agences aussi qu'on appelle agence par
exemple des des organismes comme la
Commission Informatique et Liberté comme
les autorités sectorielles de contrôle
de l'énergie des transports des télécom
et cetera là il y a beaucoup plus de
monde mais c'est pas non plus des des
des budgets très significatifs en
revanche alors là c'est un peu un autre
sujet elles ont un pouvoir normatif
c'est-à-dire qu'elles ont la possibilité
de prendre des décisions réglementaires
voir même de de de
de de je dirais de de rajouter de
d'ajouter aux normes réglementaires au
décret aux lois et cetera donc c'est un
rôle qui leur est souvent très critiquer
maintenant je pense qu'il faut les voir
un peu l'une après l'autre he c'est
c'est difficile de faire des
généralité par exemple moi je connais
mieux les les les les agences
sectorielles en matière de transport ou
d'énergie et cetera elles ont été créé à
un moment où par exemple en matière de
transport autoroute ferroviaire et
cetera on a ouvert à la concurrence
typiquement par exemple le ferroviaire
on a ouvert la concurrence on ouvre
progressivement à la concurrence le
transport ferroviaire alors que la SNCF
est t toujours un monopole sur la
gestion du réseau des infrastructures
et et donc elle a la le monopole du
réseau et elle est un opérateur comme
les autres en concurrence avec les
autres donc il y a un risque évident que
la SNCF profite de son monopole sur le
réseau pour appliquer des conditions
discriminatoires à ses concurrents qui
essayent de prendre leur place qui V
prendre sa place donc il y a besoin
d'une autorité indépendante de l'État
parce que l'État lui il est actionnaire
de la SNCF donc on a bien besoin là
d'une autorité indépendante de l'État
pour faire en sorte que bah les de
concurrence soit équitable donc celle-là
par exemple pour moi elle est nécessaire
voilà après les autres je je sais pas
bien donc je dirais c'est au cas par cas
après sur ces agences comme sur les
dépenses de l'État on peut faire des des
économies sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement bien sûr vous rappelez de
Philippe segin oui bien sûr il a été mon
premier président à la Cour des comptes
vous rappelez de son dernier discours ça
son dernier je saurais pas
dire sil attiré l'attention il signit le
il sonnait le le signal d'alarme
concernant le les perspectives de la
dette juste après la crise de c'était la
crise de 2000 combien 200728 je m'en
souviens très bien sil y a eu un moment
il y a eu un tournant stratégie je peux
vous raconter l'histoire parce que je
l'ai raconté déjà euh moi j'ai commencé
à écrire le ce rapport annuel de la Cour
sur les finances publiques en 2008 euh
il était tout nouveau euh il avait été
publié une ou deux fois avant mais sur
un registre je dirais très à plat et
quand je suis arrivé à la cour on m'a
dit il faut surtout pas
prendre il faut écrire dans un style
notarial un un déficit public ne ne
s'aggrave pas il augmente euh voilà vous
écrivez des totalement à plat notarial
et cetera donc j'ai fait ce qu'on m'a
dit de faire donc j'ai présenté il y a à
la cour il y a un organisme qui
rassemble premier président donc c'était
sgin les présidents de chambre et qui
examinent les les rapports comme celuil
là et donc on était donc en 2008 donc on
voyait qu'en 2007 la le déficit public
de la France il était déjà quasiment un
peu en dessous de 3 % du PIB à un moment
où les Allemands étaient revenus à zéro
puis 3 % du PIB c'était la limite des
règles budget européennes c'était
quiment é et donc j'avais écrit un truc
dans lequel bon on voyait quand même
assez clairement queil y avait un
problème de déficit de dette mais
c'était écrit de manière totalement PL
alors les présidents de chambre dit
c'est très bien ça montre queil y a un
risque quand même il y a un problème il
va falloir faire des efforts de
réduction du déficit et cetera Philippe
segin prend la parole dit ce rapport ne
sortira pas je le garde ici monsieur le
Président pourquoi ENF dit vous venez
tous de dire que la situation est grave
c'est pas ce que je vois dans ce rapport
vous
réécrivez moi je me suis senti très mal
C en plus il dit c'est pour la semaine
prochaine alors en fait ça s'est
brouillé on a changé les titres
c'est-à-dire au lieu d'écrire je sais
plus au lieu d'écrire le déficit public
en 2008 on a dit l'aggravation du
déficit public mais ça a été en effet un
tournant stratégique et ça lui a permis
en effet dans ses discours et cetera de
dire il y a un problème de dette et
cetera c'est grave c'est sérieux et
cetera donc j'ai j'ai vécu ce tournant
stratégique de la cour qui donc un peu
j'ai sur le moment ça m'a fa enfin sur
le moment j'ai eu des surures froides je
dit il faut que je refasse ce rapport en
une semaine mais après coup je me dis
c'est ce gar a a fait passer un tournant
à la cour à ce
moment-là comment on fait quand il y a
un délis politique quand nos nos petites
mains des ministères nos petites mains
de la Cour des
comptes travaillent comme des moines
bénédictin font émerger des bonnes
prospectives comment on fait quand un
politique il veut pas voir
l'aggravation ou l'arrivée d'un d'un
ouragan est-ce que le fonctionnaire doit
directement s'adresser à la population
est-ce que les fonctionnaires les
cabinets doivent directement dire à la
population c'est grave il faut faire
pression sur les politique faire fuiter
de l'information comment on fait non moi
je ne l'ai jamais
fait les fonctionnaires doivent être
loyaux envers qui la population ou le
ministre envers le ministre envers le
gouvernement eux ils sont pas ils ont
pas de responsab c'est les les ministres
sont le représentent un gouvernement qui
lui est responsable devant l'assemblée
donc si les prévisions sont fauses on
s'aperçoit qu'on va dans le décor c'est
à l'assemblée de censurer éventuellement
le gouvernement et puis ensuite c'est au
français de délire voilà donc dans un
régime démocratique c'est pas les les
experts fonctionnaires magistrats de la
Cour des comptes qui doivent décider ils
doivent donner des conseils donc en tant
que que fonctionnaire nous on a toujours
enfin moi j'étais je suis sûr que au
ministère des Finances ça continue on
écrit des notes au ministre pour lui
dire ce qu'on pense qu'il devrait faire
mais à l'extérieur on défend la
politique du gouvernement français moi
j'ai défendu des des des des des mesures
qui me paraissaient absurd mais je les
ai défendusquel moi j'ai défendu les 35
heur par exemple j'ai dit que c'était
très bien céit très bon aujourd'hui je
dirais que c'était une très mauvaise
idée mais à l'époque à l'époque en
interne on écrivait que c'était une
mauvaise idée donc mais à l'extérieur on
défend on défend la politique du
gouvernement donc les fonctionnaires
voilà c'est c'est la règle du jeu c'est
comme ça donc je pense pas qu'il faille
qu'il s'exprime dans le public parce que
le il il faut pas qu' il faut pas qu'il
euh qu'il metent dans leur dans le
public il diffusent dans le public leurs
notes et cetera parce que s'ils le font
moi j'ai j'ai vécu ça aussi quand
j'étais au ministère des Finances il se
trouve que une une de ces notes d'alerte
a fuité s'est retrouvé j'ai jamais su
qui l'avait fait fuiter vousz cherché
j'ai cherché bien sûr parce que ça ça
nous a emmerdé quand même pendant pas
mal de temps c'est-à-dire que pendant
plusieurs mois on a été obligé d'écrire
des qu'est-ce qu'on fait à ce moment-là
on on écrit plus de notes avec en tête
signature ça on écrit des notes blanches
sans en tête sans signature et cetera on
on on numérote toutes les notes donc
c'est c'est compliqué il a fallu en
effet que j'essaie de trou de chercher
j'ai pas trouvé la la personne voilà
donc donc ça étéit un moment un peu
pénible euh et et le résultat après le
risque après c'est que les
fonctionnaires ne disent plus que ce
qu'il pensent au ministre c'est-à-dire
que si on pense que les notes vont
fuiter se retrouver dans la presse bah
on va finir par s'autocensurer il
finissent par s'autocensurer et de pu
dire au ministres ce qu'il pensent
vraiment donc donc non il faut pas le
faire il faut quand même maintenir je
pense cette
cette une certaine manque de
transparence après en revanche la Cour
des comptes elle elle peut parler elle
est là pour parler elle a pas de pouvoir
c'est des c'est le Parlement qui décide
c'est normal dans une démocratie mais
elle a le pouvoir de parler donc elle
elle peut s'exprimer elle peut dire ce
qu'elle veut et donc il faut que donc
rejeter à la cour à après ce virage
stratégique de ce gain on n pas arrêté
dire alors on est parfois allé un peu
trop loin dire je reviens ce que je
disais tout à l'heure il faut pas trop
qu'elle dise on est au pied du mur parce
que que si le mur n'arrive pas bon finit
par pu être crédible si la France devait
passer en économie de survie qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait maintenir coûte que
coûte la police l'armée l'éducation la
SAÉ oui les fonctions régaliennes bien
sûr
la police la justice la défense et
cetera après je pense que l'éducation
oui c'est très important il y a il y a
économistes disent il y a des
externalités positiv donc c'est c'est
extrême puis dans dans tous les pays du
monde il y a quand même des subventions
de même si l'enseignement est assuré par
des écoles privées elles sont
subventionnées donc il y a voilà donc le
le l'éducation bien sûr la santé il faut
un min il y a un minimum aussi
nécessaire il faut des des dépenses de
santé les on peut laisser à la charge
des ménages peut-être une partie plus
importante des dépenses de santé euh
mais il y a il y a voilà il y a un
minimum pareil un minimum
nécessaire question
internet comment expliquer le maintien
par FCH Finch de la note double a moins
récente de la France je pense ont-ils
peur des conséquences que cela pourrait
avoir si on déclasser la note française
un effet de contamination un effet
de je suis pas dans la tête des agences
de notation euh leurs décisions sont
parfois assez politiques
euh faut bien avoir en tête la la la
note ce que font les agences de notation
c'est noter des emprunts des obligations
la base de leur boulot c'est de noter
des obligations d'entreprise sur et et
ce que représente la note c'est une
probabilité de défaut de paiement de non
paiement de de de non remboursement des
obligations quand il s'agit d'entreprise
ça se ça se repose sur des analystes
statistique qu'on peut faire parce que
il y a il y a il y a beaucoup de défauts
d'entreprise donc on peut faire des
stats et calculer des probabilités dans
le cas des états c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que heureusement il y a
c'est assez rare quand même les défauts
et donc en fait ça repose sur beaucoup
de dire d'experts donc c'est assez
qualitatif je pense que dans les
décisions des agences actuelles il y a
d'une part voilà l'idée qu'il faut en ce
moment probablement faut pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu euh jusqu'à présent
la dégradation de la note de la France
ça pas eu d'effet moi quand j'étais à la
Cour des comptes en 2012 le tout le
monde parlait de de la perte du triple A
DIT à la Cour des comptes ne dites pas
qu'il y a ça pose un problème on va
perdre notre triple A il se passera rien
il s'est rien passé ensuite on est passé
de a plus à à moins et il s'est rien
passé là il y a un risque si on passe à
simple a parce que il y a beaucoup de
dans les banques soit les les les
organismes financiers les gestionnaires
d'actifs sont obligés d'avoir des euh
des des obligations qui sont au moins
double a voilà sinon que enfin ils ont
des ratios et cetera et donc il risquent
de vendre un peu plus d'obligation
français donc il y a un risque c'est
cette fois c'est un effet sur les
marchés et ensuite je pense qu'ils se
disent aussi ils le disent pas aussi
clairement parce que c'est un peu dans
le N dit ils pensent aussi comme les
autres que de toute façon en ce moment
on est tout big tout fail de toute façon
la BCE sera toujours là donc c'est pas
la peine de dire que notre risque de
défaut a augmenté il a pas augmenté dans
le actuellement parce que on peut pas
imaginer aujourd'hui que que la France
fasse défaut donc il y a un peu tout ça
de manière un peu voilà je sais pas
comment il pondère tout ça bien sûr mais
il y a un peu tout ça dans leur dans
leur
analyse il a une question sur les autres
pays de la zone euro on verra ça plus
tard pour vous les plus gros risque que
pourrait avoir la France d'ici les trois
prochaines années
pourrait se matérialiser
comment
guerre attaque de la
dette déclassement de la note
déclassement de la note attaque de la
dette c'est un peu c'est
pareil tout
çaah je sais pas bien pondérer tout ça
c'est c'est il est certain que ce sont
des risques qui sont devant nous
qu'est-ce qui vous empêche de dormir en
ce moment concernant les finances
publiques
les finances publiques ne m'empêchent
pas trop de dormir en ce moment parce
que je pense que le le le le le le
problème n'est pas immédiat je pense
qu'on a un vrai problème à moyen long
terme très sérieux on a un mur devant
mais on n'est pas au pied du mur en
revanche des risques de conflit en
Europe sont plus
immédiats donc je je suis très inquiet
par j'ai été très très très inquiet de
ce qui s'est passé enfin de ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis en ce moment de la
du fait que Trump je dirais s'aligne sur
les position de la Russie
euh et je comprends pas bien dans
l'intérêt des Américains pourquoi parce
que je comprendrais à la limite que il
fasse ça pour attirer
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait un peu
plus de distance entre la Russie et la
Chine parce que son objectif c'est la
Chine et ceera mais mais mais pour le
moment il lui il lui il lui donne des
points je vois pas ce qu'il y a en
échange donc je comprends même pas du
point de vue des du point de vue des
États-Unis je comprends même pas son son
sa stratégie de négociation dépesser
l'Europe alors ça peut être de dépesser
l'Europe mais c'est je je vois pas non
plus l'intérêt des États-Unis à
dépeesser l'Europe que ils aiment pas
l'Europe oui d'accord
mais quel intérêt si si si si si le je
dirait leur adversaire principal c'est
la
Chine
je je sais pas un petit marcheepied h
non un petit marchepied un petit
marchepied on dépasse l'Europe on dépae
l'Europe et puis on marche sur l'Europe
comme ça on est plus facile avec la
Chine on gagne du temps bah je sais pas
en quoi ça va faciliter le sujet avec la
Chine he
c'est c'est pas ça va pas facilit ça va
pas faciliter le sujet c'est comme ce
que disait sur l'USD et cetera bon je
vois pas l'intérêt parce que la Chine va
remplacer les États-Unis pour le moment
il enfin il donne pour le moment il
donne des point à la Russie et à la
Chine je vois pas la
contrepartie comment vous voyez le fait
qu'il impose des droits de douane à
gogou sur l'Europe le Canada le Mexique
comment vous voyez cette stratégie
économique je pense que Trump c'est du
Trump bon après il peut y avoir une
certaine rationalité dans la mesure bon
les Américains ont un déficit commercial
énorme bon on peut bien voilà on peut
qu'il essaye de le réduire bon voilà il
peut y avoir une certaine nationalité
malheureusement à aller taper sur des
pays plus faibles
euh du genre Mexique can même enfin même
simplement Mexique Canada qui ont des
qui sont très dépendants des États-Unis
dans leurs
exportations qui ont un PIB une activité
bien plus faible que que celle des
États-Unis donc il peut y avoir un
intérêt à aller dans une relation
bilatérale à aller attaquer des pays
faibles parce que ils tiendront pas
longtemps euh avec des droits dran
américain ça je je je peux consir
l'Europe c'est un peu plus compliqué
parce que on est on pèse à peu près
autant que les États-Unis alors le
problème de l'Europe c'est qu'on est
divisé c'est que ce qui peut essayer de
jouer c'est la division de l'Europe donc
essayer de mettre des droits qui
touchent plus particulièrement certains
pays en espérant que ces pays à ce
moment-là je dirais s'efforceront de
faire en sorte que la la la la réplique
européenne ne soit pas à la hauteur et
cetera c'est pas évident parce que le la
politique commerciale est quand même
assez centralisée en Europe la
Commission a quand même des droits des
pouvoirs propres en matière commerciale
et si nous on ne peut pas je dirais il y
a on ne peut pas enfin on peut aussi
viser des États américains au sont des
états fédéraux c'est ce que fait
systématiquement l'Europe d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle avait déjà fait il y a il y a 8
ans c'est-à-dire viser quand on quand on
on met des droits de douane aussi élevés
que les Américains sur les Harley
Davidson je sais plus quel état
américain on vise mais on en vise un
particulier voilà on peut avoir on peut
avoir le même genre de stratégie au
total tout le monde sera perdant donc je
je trouve que c'est absurde et tout le
monde mais tout le monde va y
perdre est-ce que vous avez trois livres
à conseiller à notre communauté à ça j'y
ai pas pensé
donc qu'ils aill voir le site de fipeco
voilà très bien quels livres ont été
importants pour
vous quels livres ont été importants
dans votre vie pour le la construction
de votre
raisonnement votre façon de percevoir
les choses de la
vie
euh je ah ben je vais reciter quelqu'un
que j'ai cité tout à l'heure c'est
toville je je
entre la démocratie en Amérique et
l'Ancien Régime et la Révolution je
trouve trouve qu'il y a matière et et
c'est en lien avec avec les sujets de de
finances publies français reliseer
l'Ancien Régime et la Révolution et la
démocratie en Amérique ça ça donne des
des des un éclairage sur ce qui se passe
aussi en ce moment aussi bien en Europe
que aux États-Unis sur le dénis des
politique le dé face à la réalité oui
c'est gravissime ça non oui oui bien sûr
on prend du retard à cause de ce déis là
on gagne des vacances très cheres l'un
et l'autre
voilà est-ce que vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable j'allais dire que malgré
tout ce que je viens de
dire il faut quand même avoir alors
c'est c'est un peu la méthode Coué mais
il faut quand même avoir confiance dans
l'avenir
euh malgré tout ce que je viens de
dire essayez quand même de faire ce que
vous pouvez dans l'intérêt
dans l'intérêt
de de la France de l'Europe aussi je
essay croyer quand même quand même en
l'Europe euh ayez des enfants malgré
tout parce que le on a on on on on a
depuis 5 6 ans la France était un pays
un des pays encore où le taux de
fécondité était pas trop mauvais bon il
était pas voilà il était beaucoup mais
mais là il est en train de baisser
depuis 5 ans et quand j'écoute autour de
moi j'ai quand même plein de discours du
type on fait plus d'enfant parce que
l'avenir est
catastrophique c'est voilà c'est donc on
va pas on va on va pas on va pas leur
laisser ce monde épouvantable et cetera
je dis non il faut quand même avoir il
faut quand même avoir un peu d'espoir on
finira quand même même si on a une crise
des finances publiques faut bien payer
votre retraite même si voilà puis il
faut payer ma retraite bien sûr euh mais
là c'est les enfants de mes enfants euh
voilà même si on a une crise des
finances publiques on en a eu voilà on a
eu des crises dans passé on a on a vécu
on a eu des plans de redressement on en
a déjà eu dans en 58 on a eu un plan de
redressement qui était qui quand même
était assez dur le plan
rouf on a réussi quand même à s'en
sortir on s'est sorti de guerre en en
1870 on a payé une fortune à l'Allemagne
euh voilà c'était c'était pire que tous
les impôts qu'on peut imaginer
aujourd'hui euh bon on s'en est sorti
donc on va on va affronter des on va
certainement affronter de de lourdes
épreuves il va falloir payer très cher
mais on peut s'en sortir on fera comme à
l'époque on vendra de l'opium on vendu
de oui on avait fait la guerre à la
Chine pour lui vendre de l'opium ça
c'est les Anglais
surtoutançais un peu les Français on
avait oui on en a fait un peu aussi oui
il faut qu'on soit un peu des grands
bandits de l'économie en ce moment ou
pas il faut faire il faut faire venir
les évadés fiscaux faut faut être faut
devenir un paradis fiscal comme Irlande
non non après après on va avoir quand
même un sérieux problème qui est bon je
je je je pense qu'on a quand même un
problème de réchauffement climatique par
exemple donc il quand même des il y a
des choses à faire maintenant si on est
des seuls si l'Europe est le seul la
seule partie du monde qui fait des
efforts euh on va être mal en terme de
compétitivité de et cetera euh parce que
notre contribution à l'effet de serre
est quand même nettement inférieure à
ceux de la Chine de l'Inde même de la
Russie des États-Unis donc
euh donc j'irais pas jusqu'à dire il
faut aller en S faire comme les
États-Unis voilà et et façon façon nous
on n pas de pétrole donc on va pas forer
parce que on a rien à foré euh une de
schiste oui bon on a pas tant que ça
quand même euh donc donc et et là
d'ailleurs je dirait le le la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
rejoint nos intérêts stratégiques parce
que on on a on a intérêt quand même à
passer à des énergies décarbonées plutôt
que de dépendre du gaz du gaz russe ou
du pétrole moyenne-oriental ou du ou du
pétrole de cheist Amérique donc les les
les nos intérêts convergent mais enfin
bon voilà on on risque quand même d'être
mal dans ce monde de bandit
françoiscal merci
[Musique]